the u.s and nato have formally rejected
moscow's sweeping security demands
refusing among other things to rule out
future nato membership for ukraine in
its written reply to moscow's proposals
washington offers what it calls a
serious diplomatic path out of the
crisis
in recent weeks russia has masked some
one hundred thousand troops near its
border with ukraine stirring fears of an
attack
dw's terry schultz has been covering
this story from the beginning and joins
us now from brussels terry the u.s and
nato have now delivered written
responses to russia's security demands
what's their message
the message terry is what we've been
hearing now for weeks that it is very
important for moscow to understand that
the u.s and nato want to continue the
diplomatic dialogue but that some of
these demands are simply not acceptable
the the large one being of course that
nato would agree not to expand to other
countries notably ukraine at this point
so this is not coming as a surprise to
moscow what's in these letters which i
might point out remain classified at
this point but which we heard about in
in press briefings last night
but at the same time both the u.s and
nato are willing to talk about other
issues that are important to moscow
nuclear policy arms control possibly
even a reduction in military exercises
if moscow would agree to the same so
there are points that the u.s and nato
would like to see russia engage on but
uh they simply had to put this in
writing as the kremlin requested to show
that they were willing to continue the
diplomatic path and very much hope that
moscow will do the same
meanwhile terry russia has been carrying
out military maneuvers not just on
ukraine's borders but elsewhere as well
ukraine is not the only country feeling
threatened is it
that's right
after 2014 there was this big shock that
russia would actually cross
internationally recognized borders and
and seized territory um that belonged to
another sovereign nation so now with
this huge buildup and the fact that no
one can say exactly what's in vladimir
putin's mind there are other countries
worried about their territory in the
baltic sea in particular
and sweden has this beautiful island of
gotland that's situated right off
kaliningrad so not far from from russian
territory and from where you could if
you wanted to if you seized this island
block uh both air and naval access to
the baltic allies of estonia latvia and
lithuania as well as to finland which is
not a nato ally so i went to gotland to
see for myself just how vulnerable it
seems
in normal times the only large groups of
foreigners coming to gotland are the one
million tourists who flock to the
swedish island every year but now the
swedish government is preparing for the
possibility of unwelcome visitors as
russian president vladimir putin's
military maneuvers spread concern far
beyond ukraine
we cannot exclude an armed attack
against sweden and what we want to do
just now is to be very clear that we are
ready to defend sweden and because of
that we also are doing what we do in our
own island of goodland scotland is a
geostrategic prize duel in the baltic
sea essential for nato's access to its
baltic allies and its swedish and
finnish partners from this island you
can control both the air and seaways in
the region gotland was a key military
asset for sweden for centuries until
2005 when the swedish government
assessed post-cold war tensions as so
low that it disbanded all the permanent
military units here in what turned out
to be just wishful thinking
that's why the swedish government has
been rearming the island since shortly
after russia's seizure of ukraine's
crimea region and has intensified it in
recent weeks that gotland could be next
in the kremlin sites is no longer
unthinkable for swedes watching the
russian government continue to escalate
a bit like a game of chicken where one
of the drivers russia in this case has
just thrown the steering wheel out the
window
so we're heading unfortunate to some
kind of crash in my view defense
minister hulkqvist believes the country
has enough friends to feel safe even
without being a member of nato we have
deep cooperation with united states we
have
uk as a very close partner we are innate
the partnership we have a nordic
solidarity a doctrine and we also have a
solidarity doctrine in the european
union but being a partner to nato
doesn't provide the guarantee of mutual
defense that allies get and which paul
johnson head of the swedish parliament's
defense committee feels his country
needs we can hope we can assume we can
wish that we get the support from nato
but we cannot know until we join the
alliance a recent poll shows an
increasing number of swedes support nato
membership but that still only amounts
to about a third of the population for
now anyway if something very serious
would happen in this part of the world
mr putin decides on something in in the
baltic region here i think we would
apply very quickly
but then the question would be whether
nato would accept a country already in
dire straits especially if gotland were
gone
is there a real fear
terry that gotland could see a russian
invasion
i don't think the swedish government is
scaremongering by any stretch what they
say consistently is simply that they
can't rule it out and this is what you
hear from analysts both on and off the
record that no one knows what russian
president vladimir putin is going to do
they can only measure what he's capable
of doing and he's capable of doing a lot
and as you saw in my piece russia has
sent
naval ships into the baltic sea just
sailing by there just keeping an eye on
things and that strikes fear or at least
concern in the hearts of many so what
the swedish government is doing is just
getting ready just in case they say
terry thank you so much that was our
reporter terry schultz in brussels